Speaker 2: Thank you for having me, David.
Appreciate it.
Speaker 1: So yesterday, President Joe Biden
held his first what's called a formal press
conference in several months.
And I'm not going to go through each piece
of it because, quite frankly, most of it wasn't
very interesting.
I do think the incredible double standard
applied by many right wingers on these press
conferences should be mentioned, which is
for months and months.
They were saying, Where's Biden?
No formal press conference.
He did one yesterday.
The press wouldn't stop asking questions,
and so Biden kept going and going for nearly
two hours, and then they said he was droning
on.
It was a marathon press conference.
Nearly two hours.
He talked way too long.
Guys, you can't have it both ways, but the
piece that I want to focus on and I apologize
in advance for those who saw this yesterday
and have already suffered brain damage from
seeing it.
I'm going to play for you.
Maybe the dumbest question I have heard in
the history of journalism, and I know that
that says a lot.
Certainly, this is the dumbest question asked
of Joe Biden during his presidency.
The person asking the question is Fox News
reporter Peter Doocy.
Peter Doocy is always trying to get gotchas
and so on and so forth.
Joe Biden knows this, and yet he calls on
him basically every time.
I only remember a few instances like this,
specifically where Joe Biden has called on
Peter Doocy every single time doesn't shy
away from his questions.
Listen to the question that Peter Doocy asked,
Speaker 3: Why are you trying so hard in your
first year to pull the country so far to the
left?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
All right.
Let's let Joe Biden first start to answer.
Then I have a lot to say about this.
Speaker 3: Well, I'm not.
I don't know what you consider to be too far
to the left.
If, in fact, we're talking about making sure
that we had the money for COVID, making sure
we had the money to put together the bipartisan
infrastructure, making sure we were able to
provide for those things that in fact, would
significantly reduce the burden on working
class people.
But they can.
They have to continue to work hard.
I don't know how that is playing to left,
if you may recall.
Speaker 1: So, OK, so Joe, Joe Biden hasn't
has an answer for it.
The reason that this question is so dumb is
because the narrative around Biden's extreme
leftism is so untrue that the left wishes
this was the case.
Like, I wish Joe Biden was doing more left
wing stuff.
Think about Biden's major actions during his
first year as president, and this is not like
a report card.
It's just evaluating whether the things he
did are really left or not.
He did COVID stimulus now.
Trump did two of them.
Biden's COVID stimulus is no further left
than Trump's two COVID stimuli.
Biden did one.
Trump did, too.
So that's a major accomplishment.
He did it relatively quickly.
Once getting in office, not very far left.
Number two, The vaccine rollout has been one
of Joe Biden's kind of major actions or proto
programs during his first year.
If you believe Trump made the vaccines, which
he didn't, but let's imagine that we kind
of accept this right wing story that that
Trump made the vaccines.
How is distributing the vaccines that your
Republican hero made far left so that that's
not far left?
Joe Biden got a very modest infrastructure
bill passed and remember that for a very long
time, Republicans liked infrastructure spending
to some degree.
And there's nothing particularly far left
about it.
You know, center centrist governments around
the world do infrastructure.
Right wing governments around the world do
infrastructure.
Left wing governments around the world do
It's a very modest infrastructure bill, quite
milquetoast.
If I say so myself.
Getting out of Afghanistan is a major first
year Biden accomplishment.
That was the Trump plan.
So how is Biden doing the thing that Trump
promised to do?
Far left.
Not seeing anything that matches that description.
These are the major Biden accomplishments
during year one now just rolling out sending
for free COVID tests to anybody who asks for
them.
But you've got to ask for them.
There is nothing very far left here and a
lot of this.
So so there's really two stories here.
One story is the false narrative about Biden
being an extreme leftist.
I think that Biden ran on a policy that's
like marginally to the left of Barack Obama,
and certainly the implementation has been
extraordinarily center left.
Nothing remarkable at all.
And then it's just this.
Vatican flaccid continued attempt from Peter
Doocy to make himself seem alpha for lack
of a better term and do a big boy for the
Fox News audience, which I think is kind of
working for him.
Like I think if the Fox audiences, why are
you trying to move the country so far to the
left?
They probably do believe that that's what
Joe Biden is trying to do, even though it
could not be further from the truth.
I am having a hard time, and I know Newsmax
and OAN sometimes ask questions of presidents.
This seems like the dumbest question posed
to a president
in
a very, very long time.